[Music]
hey what's going on everybody let's have
the argument about how where the camera
is and how the lighting is okay is it
okay it's a little
white see I didn't change
anything okay it's going this way goes
it this
way okay
we're just like so you you like that
better
yeah okay all right something's
different I don't think it is dude it
look really dark in the backg I haven't
touched anything looks really dark in
the I didn't turn anything off back
there unless the some of the little
lights down I think okay maybe I didn't
do it though that that's all you it was
just like that that's all you
yeah but yeah hey it's Friday it's it's
Friday the 13th that's why the the
little uh what the [__] is that thing
called yeah what the [__] is that thing
called the little thumbnail that's why I
put Jason on there um it was actually
kind of funny because I did I went and
like did an AI and I just put in Jason
Vorhees Friday the 13th and I was so
amused that the AI came up with
something that looked very much like
Jason bores but he also like had a
little backpack on like he was going to
summer camp and I thought that was very
very funny so I said well that's I'm
going to use that one cuz Sebastian up
he's like with his Rock sack and I was
like well you know he's got to have
somewhere to keep his machete and his
protein bars you know what I mean got to
keep your uh energy up for slashing all
those horny teenagers okay so we
are welcom you all to the weekend we
usually uh have a few drinks we're going
out tonight we're going out to uh M Mor
is evening Friday the 13th edition yeah
barbarell
so I'm just gonna have just one drink
I'm not gonna get too [__] up we're
trying to get got Drive yeah yeah and
then um we'll probably end the show 9:00
our
time somewhere around there yeah about
an hour and a half probably Zach says uh
my hair and shirt make it look like I'm
wearing a nuns habit well nothing wrong
with
that yeah this is actually my real hair
which I don't usually do yeah cuz I just
colored it yesterday and washed it and
combed it all out and Tom cut the bang
shorter
yeah so we're just kind of we're just
kind of like rolling with it like that
yeah rolling with it like that cuz I
take the glasses off show them show them
without the glass there you go it does
look better without the glasses yeah it
looks a lot better without the glasses
but I can't see [__] without the glasses
everything just looks like little Wiggly
blares yeah and the side of her face
like give her give a profile cuz she the
other way she's totally bald I shaved
everything yeah yeah it looks good well
that's been like that for a while yeah
to the razor though normally I would
wear it up but Tom's like I don't know
it looks good like kind of down yeah so
I guess I'm rolling with that yeah wear
it down I'm rolling with that trying to
be all like elegant this evening I guess
yeah she's got a cool long dress on yeah
look at this new little thing look at
the little hearts that are that are
moving who's doing that the heart
special effect yeah that must be a new
thing because I use OBS and so I have
like a little chat window that's like
the YouTube chat window and a couple
days ago I noticed that they now have
like a little emoji button like at the
bottom which never happened before and
so now it's like a heart and then
there's now every now and then like
little hearts go woo and they go like
and I'm like wow look at that I'm
impressed like by really simple things
obviously so you know yeah he wants to
know if we can talk about what's going
on in Israel yeah you I talk about that
I've been uh studying it seeing what's
going on looked at the videos uh the
ones that we could find um but uh no if
you have any any uh questions you know I
can answer them
also got uh one friend over there who's
a friend of the show she listens to the
show that that's uh she's in Greece
right now uh but all her family's back
in Israel her I think it was one of her
sisters or cousins or something was at
that Rave that got uh where the where
the airborne troops
landed they survived though you they at
that ra yeah Z says uh it's like mortia
meets Elizabeth cander and I'm here for
it well thank you I I appreciate it
because I those are both my style icons
so I didn't like mean to do it like that
but that's just kind of how it worked
out cuz this was some of the new these
dresses we got from Teemu right yeah the
newest ones um they they all look good
yeah I like all of them actually we got
like a lot of kind of long ones show
them this one well this one yeah it
looks a lot better I don't have any
shoes on boots on but it looks Bo hold
on let me get over here wow okay but
yeah classy I'm
classy yeah see it's kind of got like a
tribal yeah turn patter in the bottom
and it's like slit up the side yeah with
boots it looks a lot better yeah but
like I said yeah I like to sit
cross-legged in a chair and it's kind of
hard to do that with boots on yeah so
I'll put some on later before you before
we go out but yeah they all uh did turn
out looking really good so there's that
um um but
yeah Zach says which version of Dragon
Tattoo did you like more the Swedish
movies or the David Fincher one I love
the fure movie The Swedish ones had a
made for TV look to them I don't like
much um I liked both of them I kind of
feel like I probably slightly like the
David finer ones better but I think they
were both good those books were amazing
though I [__] I just tore through all
the books like I think in a few days and
they're long you know what I mean I
don't really have an opinion on them I
didn't they really really weren't my
D yeah um like I said I liked the books
a lot better but the movies were a good
adaptation but of course they had to
leave a lot of [__] out like they always
do so you know what I
mean oh I meant to say I don't think
Oscar is here but he asked me to do a
review of VHS
85 which just dropped on shudder a
couple days ago so um I actually did
watch it and I wrote out a thing so I am
going to do hopefully over the weekend
I'll record
and uh I'll record and edit the the
thing so you know so that'll be good I
don't like I said I don't usually like
found footage all that much um I mean
you know there's a lot of ones I like
but I actually just spoiler alert I
actually really liked VHS 85 I thought
they did a good job with it there was a
couple stories in there that were kind
of like not as good as the other ones
but like the ones that were really good
were really really good I think it's my
second favorite one of all all of them
cuz I did a review over on my scar Salon
channel of all five of the ones that
were out back then you know what I mean
I think Oscar asked me to do that too so
it was like this big long I think the
video was like an hour long and I talked
about all five of the ones so I thought
might as well do VHS 85 too I heard that
the next one they're doing cuz this one
was so successful for a shutter that
they've already green lit another one
and I think the next one is going to be
all like
sci-fi focused which I'm not that jazzed
about but it might be good we'll
see Zach says Uh there's a movie based
on the Silent Hill games coming out next
year and I can't wait for it yeah um
didn't they make one didn't they make a
Silent Hill movie like a while back I
remember being okay but I never played
the game so I don't I know everybody
like Raves about those but I've never
really um you know I I never really like
got that into them you know what I mean
uh Tammy said you should review Renfield
since you've watched it yeah I probably
will I actually really liked it Tom
didn't see all of it because he was out
at bike night and I started watching it
like before he got
back but um it was I don't know I really
dug it it was like a little bit
different than what I was expecting but
it was like super funny like and
especially like all the gore and stuff
like that was [__] hilarious you know
what I mean like I [__] loved that
[__] like I love the priest exploding at
the beginning too that like made me
laugh out
loud okay I got to address the serious
[__] that they're saying they're
thinking that the um based on their
comments they're thinking that the uh
that there was something fishy about
that Hamas attack them flying in and
everything um n you have to understand
Mo most of warfare is
psychological and uh even the physical
aspects of it there's a big
psychological and emotional element
behind
it what happened with Israel is they got
normaly
bias Hamas hadn't done anything in a
long time and uh the last thing Hamas
basically told him is that they were
just going to focus on the
economy I saw videos of those uh uh
little
motorized ultra light hand glider things
you know coming in and all the damn
little parachute guys the parag gliders
coming in but that the uh the ultral
light aircraft the dude made a [__]
perfect landing and it had a two-man
crew guy they had a gunner up front and
a pilot in the back and I saw that L
landing and I was like man those dudes
have been
practicing because you know just a
perfect landing and I was thinking where
could you have practiced that inside
Gaza without attracting attention and I
was looking at some of the guys in there
and some of the guys look like
Ethiopians or Egyptians you know in the
attack you know real dark skinned and
they didn't really look like guys from
Gaza they didn't so I was thinking it's
probably an international
volunteer group in other words
mercenaries Islamic mercenaries which it
probably
was and I thought maybe they had maybe
trained for that up in Africa cuz uh the
Russians are in there you know with the
Vagner group and that'd be a
good place and a good team to train
those guys
Bogner but then I found out more
information turned out H had a training
camp inside Gaza and they were
practicing flying those things and
Landing the paragliders they were even
taking selfies for years they've been
training that [__] for
years and uh Landing those things and
doing
drills they had uh mockups of certain
areas of [__] of the of towns inside
Israel where they considered were high
priority targets and they were uh
running drills through it Israel
knew but they had normaly bias
they didn't believe it they thought they
thought that that was just Hamas
propaganda training and recruitment
because you want to keep your crew you
want to keep your troops trained and
training is part of the morale to get
new recruits they didn't think they'd
ever pull a trigger on that
mission but the timing alined up you
know Saudi Arabia and Israel were going
to sign this
agreement and that would have put himos
fing in an inferior position so they put
pull the trigger on that mission and now
foiled the uh the uh I guess you could
say the agreement between Saudi Arabia
and um Israel because Israel doesn't
want to be seen supporting you know
excuse me Saudi Arabia doesn't want to
be seen supporting Israel in front of
all these enraged
Arabs so it wasn't just that it was
fishy in terms of you know oh well they
knew and they could have stopped it yeah
they knew about the training but
everybody's training at all times for
all different kinds of missions all
armies are training constantly doesn't
mean anything doesn't mean they're
actually going to pull a trigger on any
of
that but they did you know and uh what
the reason why they wanted it Not only
was to foil that agreement Hamas had a
lot of has a lot of their guys in prison
inside
Israel so they wanted a big shock and
all campaign and they wanted to grab a
bunch of captives so they could trade
them off and get their guys out of
prison
it's going to backfire though Israel's
going to [__] level that
place um it's not pretty you know I
don't really I don't really back either
one you know what I mean it's not I
don't really have a dog in that
fight
um I think Hamas is desperate you know
they they desperately want their cause
to continue they don't want an Israel to
exist they don't even want Jews you know
so they're just going to they're going
to do [__] like that and Israel now has
to fight fight to survive which that's
the that's the law of the Jungle and and
that's what this is is nothing's in
control of anything everything is just
the jungle and everything is just an
animal in the jungle all these
organizations are just animals in the
jungle and you just uh they're all
fighting and that's way it's always
going to be it's way the way it's all
been through the history of mankind and
even before man was man back when we
were animals we were still doing that
nothing's
changed but uh I think it's going to
backfire Israel's going to [__] level
that place and that might backfire so it
might be an endless cycle but that's
just how it
is yep there's always going to be
somebody holding the pair of Anguish and
there's always going to be somebody
getting the pair of Anguish shoved up
their rect the pair of Anguish gets
passed around we all got it coming sure
everything imposes on everything else in
nature even inanimate objects [__] over
other inanimate objects by occupying
spaces that another inanimate object
could occupy you cannot exist in any
kind of state of righteousness you're
always
imposing at least a little yeah you know
yeah so just is what it
is right what are you going to do I mean
yeah it is the way of the
world you're so wise Tom oh but here's
the deal they want to know well who
trained these guys don't sell them guys
[__]
short Hamas train themselves they you
know they're intelligent guys they got
spree deor they got purpose that they
want to they got their purpose that's
you know the religious motiv motivations
ethnic
motivations and uh part of a good
professional soldiers is to be creative
and inventive and use the things you
have at hand and practice with those and
that's what they did paragliders and
ultr light aircraft man that's a good
idea and they were not expensive and
they used them and they also did an
amphibious assault people don't realize
that they went there were speed boats
too so it was land see and air
motorcycles
jeeps and they did it to show everybody
they could do
it uh you don't need high technology you
don't want high technology you want
cheap disposable [__] that you don't see
coming you
know I think the speedboats were
inflatable Israeli Navy blew ble blew at
least one up though I saw the video just
vaporized it but that was not that
wasn't the point the point was is just
shocking off
that they can come from anywhere
whenever they want to that was the idea
Zach says and then the Austrian guys see
the pair of Anguish and start drooling
yeah you know freaky [__] ger we
should probably yeah I yeah that's what
I was when you said that freaky [__]
J I was thinking of think his video we
were watching for because Tom is always
he's a porn connoisseur like I said and
he's always kind of like which I I think
this is this may sound weird but I think
this is very nice that you do this he
will actually like look for porn I think
Jenny would like this you know what I
mean even if it's not really his thing
based on the nasty [__] she says man and
the [__] she threatens me with right
she's cruel she's real [__] cruel I
would never do anything bad to you you
know that though I mean you know that
I'm just [__] with you because it's
funny because it makes you uncomfortable
so so yeah so he says to me yesterday
he's like oh I found some horn that
you're going to really dig um he's like
so so last night he shows it to me and
it was this um these this real hot um I
guess she was German she was speaking
English but it sounded like a German or
Austrian accent it's a German couple and
um she's tattooed like pretty much over
her whole body her eyeballs are tattooed
like her tongue is split and tattooed um
blue she's blue yeah like it's blue
she's actually really pretty and she has
like these really pretty like blue
dreadlocks her face isn't tattooed
totally it's still white but it's got
stripes and slash marks it's cool
looking the rest is all just patterns I
really liked it and her husband is the
same same way he got matching there it
kind of matches so it's like the funny
thing is that when she's naked it almost
looks like she's not naked because she
has so many she like she got clothes on
she's got like solid blocks and it's
it's actually like really cool looking I
think it's like really aesthetically
nice she also has nipple piercings but
they are behind the areolas and it
looked like the meat yeah like through
the meat and I was like I wonder would
that be more or less painful we were
thinking maybe that would be less
because that skin is softer back there
but it's like yeah it's like behind the
areola and she had like a um like a it
kind of looked like a plastic plastic
tea screw or like a tea kind of thing
and it's like up here and like it stuck
out the bottom like the bottom and
there's a cap on there and so something
medical yeah yeah so she had that
through each tit yeah and then um she
had a bunch of other piercings to like
in her lips and stuff got one above and
below this damn Brown C like with the
button and she had like yeah yeah the
big long stretched ears and stuff like
that but like I said she was really
really beautiful she pretty no whites in
her eyes everything's blue yeah it's
like I said it's a cool look and it's a
whole like aesthetic and I kind of dug
it so it's her and I'm assuming her
boyfriend husband or whoever because
they have like kind of matching
aesthetic like tattoos yeah um so it was
him he's laying on the table and I was
like oh this is getting good yeah and
it's her and then this other woman who I
guess is the sounding expert yeah and
they are she's not tattooed at all she's
not tattooed at all but had like fetish
clothes on looks like 1920's fetish
Queen yeah yeah yeah she had like kind
of a bob kind of thing like also really
pretty fresh from The Cabaret and so the
whole video was him laying on this
medical table and the one girl like
sounding him and then the other like the
wife like just sticking this big huge
like metal thing up his St the steel rod
like this big a damn ball on it it's
about 3 feet long that ball was like the
size of a tennis ball Uris that Tom sat
through the sounding thing because it's
like well yeah because they start out
with like the little small if you don't
know what sounding is because we were uh
streaming today we were over on stream
eight and we mentioned something about
it and the guy didn't know what that was
he's like what's that and we told him
what it was and he's like
nope but yeah basically you take like
little metal rods and you stick them
down your dick hole like in the your WRA
yeah and then it's like and then there's
a set of them and they're not straight
they're [__] kind of curved and then
like you just get bigger bigger so the
biggest one in this set was probably
like bigger around than a pencil yeah
about as bigger around I was like [__]
she's really going to get that in his
dickle and I was like yep she certainly
did bigger bigger around than a very
large [__] and the two girls were
just like having the time with their
life and stuff and they're just like o
here it goes look at that and I was just
like oh my God this is the greatest
thing ever this say that [__] strong
accent we have to fill up all these
holes [__] see Tom knows me too well
he's like you're going to love this [__]
watch yeah that's J likes all that
[__] perverted
filling up all these holes I love all
that [__] and then they had another one
where it was the same two girls but it
was a different dude and I guess this
was a dude that they knew because he was
in a couple of other videos with them
too yeah but um he was tattooed all over
like think they all live together on the
same compound yeah actually it's like an
artist whoever filmed this was like a
professional like I mean the editing was
nice like all the shot compositions were
nice which I know is a crazy thing to
say about form but it looked really good
um you know there was good sound quality
sound like good music in the background
like doing closeups on [__] tools
yeah doing close-ups and stuff like the
way it was edited was like I was like
wow this is great so um yeah they they
really knew what they were doing but
this guy he was tattooed like like all
over like even the bottoms of his feet
like up in his [__] like everything
was tattooed like his entire dick was um
tattooed everything he was like blue his
whole face was blue yeah and he was kind
he was pretty cool looking too and he
also kind of had dreads and stuff so
this guy they he also crossdressing yeah
yeah well in this he was in this one he
had like kind of white blouse and he had
like these white um thigh eyes or
whatever so they put him on the same
table like these same two women yeah
they're all in good shape these people
are all oh yeah they're all like really
super attractive people they look like
models so um so yeah they they first
like they tied his dick up with rope and
like put it all around his balls and
everything like that and kind of like
hog tied it and then kind of like tied
him up like that and then they just like
stuck bigger and bigger things like up
his ass they were both sticking huge
fists up his ass and all F yeah it was
great and then so it's like you're
chiding him about [__]
gaping come on you can do it just kind
he couldn't do it so I was like we I was
like favorite this channel I like this
but um I like that femdom stuff yeah Fe
he was he was looked like he was in
agony but he didn't go anywhere well I
was like yeah and like I said he was in
some of the other videos with them so um
they're pain freaks man there we got all
the [__] tattoos and weird parcing
and [__] that's what I mean because like
I said you got to be into that [__] to
like get your whole ENT Tire dick and
your butthole tattooed just saying yeah
cuz I'm not even going to do that so but
yeah that girl was like that too though
too yeah yeah was tattooed up in there
yeah she hers was it wasn't quite as
extreme but yeah she had tattoos she
only place she didn't have tattoos in
the bottoms of her feet in her face yeah
most of her face she did have some
tattoos on her face but not not all over
yeah let's
see they're still talking about
uh the stuff still talking about all
that Jeffy art said I used to work at a
leather fetish shop in Fort Lauderdale I
went to some fetish parties down there
back in the old days and was educated by
a customer regarding sounding it was
described as getting jerked off from the
inside I'm way too vanilla for
that yeah I mean I'm looking at that and
I'm like I I would not blame a dude for
not wanting that done to them it doesn't
look super comfortable
but I don't know I don't know what do
you think Tom would you want to be would
you want to be
sounded man you look at that your hair
[__] stands up yeah he was just
[Laughter]
like it must feel good it seems like it
feels good but [__] well he was
pretty chill about it he was just like
all right yeah I don't know man I'm
scared of it it looks painful from the
outside I will say that
but maybe it's not you know yeah I don't
know hard to say maybe it's you [__]
I remember woke up from a damn basically
a coma they were pulling a catheter out
of me [__] when I was in that
motorcycle wreck [__] sent me through
the roof oh I can imagine yeah and that
was a young woman at 20s yanked that
thing out she didn't know yeah I was
like she looked like she was surprised
cuz she thought I was unconscious it
[__] like well I was unconscious
until he did that [__] yeah I
[__] yeah woke up she pulled that
thing out of there it had been in there
for days oh yeah I mean I would think I
don't know I'm not a nurse yeah but I
would think that even if the person was
unconscious I'd be like well just to be
on the safe side I'm going to do this
very carefully and slowly you know what
I mean but maybe not maybe some people
like he's asleep it doesn't feel it well
maybe it's better if it's all at once I
think it got stck stuck up in there
dried and stuck you know what I mean so
there was no nothing was lubed or
anything right didn't slide out it a pop
you know it's like it was like ripping
off a damn scab or something yikes yeah
at least it was over quick yeah maybe
maybe got a point yeah and I rolled over
and [__] p uh passed back out again
went back to sleep I remembered it well
that's well yeah I remembered it yeah
cuz you told me that last night you were
like yeah it's kind of like that's what
it kind of varied you of yeah and that
girl looked at me her eyes are big as
saucers you
okay sorry yeah I was [__] sorry I
just pulled that out of a very
uncomfortable place oh man
Zach says getting jerked out from the
inside is an upsetting combination of
words I guess Tammy says you have to
pick one pegged or sounded oh sounded he
would definitely pick sounded yeah he is
absolutely not because it seems like
every time we stream somebody comes in
conly ask me for that yeah about that so
that must be like really common and like
we had a dude today dudes are like man
you all you're missing out you yeah it's
like it's so awesome you should let her
do it and I'm just like okay
either that or it's the same person with
lots of
different like [__] with you cuz they
know you don't want to do it and I'm
just like see he won't let me he won't
let me yeah they ask for it every day
pretty much I think every time we go on
somebody ask for it it's like [__]
hilarious we had one we had one to Dave
loving on me like
crazy wanted me to sh wanted me to show
him everything yeah he went cam to cam I
couldn't see him though yeah he went cam
to can but his camera camera wasn't
working I just pretended like I could
yeah it's like uh hey you we can we can
see Dak says uh no what you need to do
is use the pair of Anguish on time first
and then peg
him see everybody wants to see everybody
wants to see that y are sick well like I
said cuz it's more fun because you don't
want it to happen you know what I mean
let me get some ice I probably need some
too look at that it just melts yeah I
don't know it might be the juice doing
that or the FL Florida doing that I'm
not really sure Lara says uh J&B whiskey
in jellow just because of the yellow
label I always wondered about that too
like why do they always I don't know how
common like J&B whiskey is in Europe so
maybe it was just kind of a thing and
like somebody just noticed it but it
does seem like they very conspicuously
like put bottles of J&B whiskey in Galo
movies like and I I don't really know
why that is even they've even done like
newer jalo movies um you know or or like
Neo Galo that are kind of parodying or
homaging the genre and they'll put jmb
whiskey in there too so obviously I'm
not the only person that's noticed that
what's that the J&B whiskey bottles that
turn up in um Gala movies
oh it's probably easy to find that in
Italy well that's what I was wondering I
said I wonder I wondered if it was just
kind of like happened to be there cuz
that was a common brand and then people
just noticed it because those movies got
exported to other countries Maybe and
they're like hey look at all the J cuz
we have J&B whiskey here too but it's
like not all that I remember in the 7s I
remember in the 70s out in California
J&B whiskey there were Billboards of it
for everywhere so it was just I think it
was just a time when that was a real
popular brand of whiskey it's not
anymore I've had it before like a few
years ago yeah Jack Daniels and wild
turkey and [__] like that Jim Beam Jack
Daniels and Jim Beam sell a lot more
yeah I mean I like J&B it's it's not
really um I didn't really notice that
much of a difference between that and
like and there isn't there isn't a big
advertising campaign behind it J&B had
an advertising campaign behind it he
also had Cy Sark there was a huge
[__] huge [__] advertising
campaign behind that and I think that
might be some kind of vermouth isn't it
what is that what the [__] even is that
I remember all the ads but I don't even
like I was too young to drink when those
odds were popular that they had a brown
one and a green one I think yeah weird
shape I don't even know what it was
though yeah what the [__] it might have
been whiskey what the [__] is
cyar might be whiskey we drink a lot but
I'm not real um that's old people [__]
that yeah well and I'm not real
sophisticated when it comes to like all
these different I'm just like H
whatever's kind of cheap like not super
super cheap I'm not that much of a I'm
not that trashy but you like bargain
stuff yeah I just kind of like bargain
bargain vodka yeah well Vodka it's kind
of hard to mess up you know what I mean
like once you get into real cheap VOD is
terrible though well yeah yeah yeah well
that's what I was going to say was that
yeah if you get something like [__]
what's that [__] that they um that was
the Aristocrat Aristocrat would you get
like Aristocrat that just tastes like
rubbing alcohol yeah Aristocrat tastes
Terri but once you get into the Pinnacle
you know Sky area I mean those are fine
that's actually mid tier yeah th those
are fine yeah not a don't go cheaper
than that yeah there's not much
difference between the mid tier and the
[__] higher tier what I'm saying now
I will note that when I worked for Van
go and I don't even think they make it
anymore when I worked for Van go vodka I
will note that that stuff did taste
better um but it was more expensive it
was like 30 bucks for just like not even
for like the smaller size bottle but all
their [__] was like natural they didn't
use any artificial flavors or anything
like that and it was imported like they
made it in Holland I want to say
I don't know somewhere like that hey no
you leave those alone what is she doing
tearing up your boots oh Pokey no no
she's like oh boy new shees to [__] up
no she looked at me like why you hit me
with that she couldn't believe it I that
I hit her with the with the tow with the
r well see the thing about it Pooky is
very Pooky is very smart yeah but we
kind of I she's kind of allowed to like
tear up on [__] like CU you can't stop
her I mean she tears up the carpet she
tears up the chairs and stuff like that
but we don't want to really tearing up
shoes yeah so she doesn't seem to
understand it's like well hey I can tear
up this chair why can't why can't I tear
that up there's no difference don't you
do it Pokey no she's looking at that
chew again and now one neither no she
does know what no means though yeah she
knows what no means yeah she's just
trying to pretend like she didn't hear
it like I wasn't going to do that okay
there you go there you go stop doing
that [__] cuz she likes to jump up on
the sink in the in my bathroom and I
have this kind of like vase thing that
has this top on it with a metal like a
silver metal thing on the top and she
loves to [__] chew on that and she
knows she's not supposed to yeah so
she'll jump up there and she'll very
casually kind of walk over them I'm like
don't you chew on that and then she'll
be like well I wasn't going to I was
just going to rub on it see I'm just
rubbing but then like when you turn your
head away she's like and then she start
like OT she knows when you're know look
she understands deception and then
you're like no and then she's like I
wasn't yeah yeah she's funny she knows
all about deception she doeses play [__]
off she does she's very sneaky well she
thinks she's very sneaky b says that
[__] uh sky goes down real smooth
Sky's good mhm but there's very little
difference between sky and
Pinnacle I usually get Sky if if it's
available and uh I can't really tell the
difference between
Sky Sam's Sam's vodka Sam's is what we
have right now yeah we Sam's right now
and it's good
uh and and Gray Goose yeah Sam's and
greay Goose about the
same like I said what she get up to that
price point where she's like you know
sky is about 26 bucks for a big fifth
and then Sam's a big one is like 21 yeah
for Sam's vodka and I'd really take the
Sam's vodka over Sky though because it's
closer to Gray Goose Gray Goose is
pretty good too it's a bit cheaper
actually that seems like it's gone up
because when I used to buy the Sam's
vodka it was like 17 bucks not even I
think it was like 14
I think it was $3.99 for big one and it
came in a pretty bottle yeah and they
Sam's Silver Tequila is excellent I
can't tell it apart from mro Silver yeah
I don't know who makes it it's good
probably mro and I think we've said this
before but the only Sam's liquor that we
didn't like was the Whiskey yeah
terrible it tasted like looking a
barbecue grill really artificial flavor
yeah it was very it had that yeah it
tasted like liquid smoke more more than
whiskey yeah which I was just kind of
like I don't mind a smoky whis but
that's a little much in its defense I
tried Johnny Walker Red Label recently
and it was also terrible it was nowhere
near as good as it used to be when I was
a kid red label was good I haven't had
Johnny Walker in a long time red label
and black label used to be really good
they're not that good
anymore I like I like whiskey but I
don't drink it that often like we don't
usually have it at the house like
sometimes I'll drink it when I'm out
like I'll just get like whiskey and Coke
or something but I could tell that the
Sam's whis Scotch whiskey and the
and Johnny
Walker could tell they were artificially
flavored [__] didn't taste right yeah it
was too strong too
smoky just like man that that's not
right yeah I don't really like that kind
of artificial Smokey flavor does not
compare at all to say like a [__]
really good like Glen fiic or Glenn
livet man that shit's [__] really
good yeah real Scotch
whiskey I saw something here it's like
murder Hornet said I can get wild turkey
101 a liter in Mexico for $20 yeah
that's pretty good actually Jeffy said
during my bougie phase I loved using the
flavored van go for my chocolate
espresso martinis yeah their espresso
vodka was really good I don't think they
make it anymore says now I just use day
old coffee Hershey syrup Bailey and
smear it off there was a drink not going
to lie I would probably drink that too
that sounds pretty good there was a
drink they had a a menu or a [__] not
a menu what you call it they had a a
recipe book yeah I have it somewhere so
from when I used to work there and they
had one it
was was it peanut butter vodka PB&J no
not that one peanut butter
vodka with caramel
vodka cocacola with a ring of salt and
it it tasted just like an O Henry bar or
like a Payday payday payday bar wasn't
it well it wasn't they didn't make just
peanut butter vodka they made PB&J right
that was their big thing okay then it
wasn't PB&J it was
was Caramel Vodka Coca-Cola and ring of
salt no it was the it was the PBJ it was
PB&J was it because that was one of the
signature when I first started working
there I think in
2013 um that was their newest one
because they were trying to compete with
Pinnacle I think Pinnacle just put out a
peanut butter vodka or something yeah so
it's like we got to go one more and make
a
PB&J so they did although to me it just
tasted like peanut butter I didn't taste
any jelly in there and honestly like if
you wanted CU they did have a cocktail
That was supposed to taste like a peanut
bur jelly sandwich but the thing about
it was that to give it the jelly taste
you had to add raspberry vodka like to
kind of pump up the grape flavor that
was in there cuz I I thought the grape
flavor in the PB&J was pretty
indistinguishable like I couldn't yeah
so it just tasted like peanut and I
really like peanut butter vodka and
peanut butter whiskey but that that uh
that payday recipe
[__] uh van go payday Drake man
wasn't it payday
yeah yeah I me it was they didn't call
it that obviously it was tasted like a
candy bar it did yeah it was it was real
salty and peanut salty peanut with chocy
kind of man it was so good it was real
good I think do remember when we had
that like that big party at our house
yeah when we lived in Sanford and I
think we made those cuz I think they
were still making PB and J vodka back
then and man we got like pretty [__]
trashed on those cuz they were
[Laughter]
delicious uh but yeah those were good
yeah I I kind of feel like was it
caramel VOD I can't remember there was
another flavor of vodka that was it
might have been caramel think it was
caramel I'm trying remember peanut
butter and caramel and cocacola yeah
with a ring of salt around yeah and then
you had to have like all the salt and I
think it might have had something else
in it I have that Booker didn't have
grenadine in it did it no no it was just
that I'm pretty sure that was it they
were addictive you could drink them you
could drink a lot of them and you could
drink them quickly yeah they were strong
though but they didn't taste strong they
were yeah you could drink it like it was
soda they were delicious I really really
liked them because it was carbonated and
it was just like man that's
good yeah once you drank it there was
something about that caramel and the
salt and the peanut and the and the
sugar from the from the cocacola and it
was just like you'd take a hit of that
and like wow and then you'd immediately
want to drink more and you I'd want to
take big
strong you know what I mean but you
didn't realize how much alcohol that was
it's a lot didn't taste strong it was
very strong you had to respect those
things I mean well I think the
combination I was like the combination
of like sweet and salty that's always
like really really good but um you know
like I'll eat chocolate covered potato
chips all day long that sh is delicious
old school van go was good it was real
good quality yeah like I said it wasn't
cheap but it was worth it I mean they
used all natural flavors it was good
quality [__] and it just couldn't beat
out they just couldn't beat out pinnacle
pinnacle was a fraction of the cost and
what is it like 12 bucks or something it
was artificially flavored but you don't
give a [__] this just's flavored so well
you just depending on the flavor some of
them are too much but yeah yeah some of
them like I don't really like cake
wasn't all that it was okay best one was
uh whipped cream vodka yeah that with
with orange juice beautiful yeah that's
really good cuz you're going to mix it
with [__] anyway usually yeah if it's
flavored and I actually don't even mind
um the Cherry one if you mix it with
like Sprite or something like that or
Coke is good too cuz then you have like
kind of a Cherry Coke or cherry Sprite
experience the Cherry kind of had
artificial flavor to yeah but I don't
mind artificial cherry flavor and then
birthday cake remember that yeah yeah
birthday cake birthday cake one was
pretty good yeah but now but I mean they
just pulled out all the stops cuz
they're just like we're going to be
known as like the flavored vodka of of
you know broke college kids so they're
like we're going to do the craziest
[__] flavors that you can do so it's
like they had [__] like Froot Loops and
all that other yeah they were good I see
I don't like Froot Loops in real life so
yeah they were good so I didn't really
like the FR Loops either all different
kinds of candy I'm trying to think now I
think the big Trend now is like pickle
flavored ones yeah which I can kind of
get behind that's easy to do though you
get the pickle juice out of the jar just
put vodka in that I could drink pickle
juice I could too I love pickle juice
yeah I used to think it was bad for you
turned out no they said you can drink
all that you want no it's not right not
said it does something to your blood
it's pretty good that vinegar in there
yeah Jeffy art said I love salty and
sweet I take pretzel chips and dunk them
in chunky peanut butter then spread
strawberry preserves on there that does
sound pretty good actually that's a lot
of carbs I mean all that [__] is good
one of my favorite um coffee drinks that
I discovered at not Starbucks but at Joe
mugs which is the cafe inside books
million in the fall they have what is it
salted caramel
pecan latte yeah that's a good one and
that's I've tried all of them I tried
the Pumpkin Spice one the the red velvet
one's pretty good too um and they had
like some other like caramel apple like
they had some other ones like that too
but man that salted caramel peon one is
like that's the [__] right there
oracle's here what's up Oracle hey
what's up yeah Tammy's here
too I think Tammy's been here though
yeah yeah yeah I saw her
earlier Tammy say says they make a PB&J
moonshine that tastes like peanut butter
as you breathe in and jelly as you
breathe out tasted it in Gatlinburg
hm we should probably try some more I
wish those moonshines those Old Smoky
moonshines weren't so expensive yeah and
they're kind of not really not a lot
bang for your book they're
weak well you know they have like such
cool flavors cuz man that butter pecan
one was good and the strawberry one was
pretty good now the strawberry one was
pretty strong I thought for the money I
could set a still up in the [__]
kitchen and make that Tom's going to put
a still in the kitchen yeah well [__]
start manufacturing the [__] we'll make
some money yeah well you don't no then
you get into it's a federal
fit making and selling alcohol without
the tax St when has that ever stopped us
yeah well you can give it away you can
drink it for your own use sure but you
you can't sell it you can't package it
sell it but um it's easy to make that
[__] they sell whole Stills pre-made
ready to go off the
internet you just need the little
condensing coils and [__] it's it's not
a difficult recipe
um You probably wouldn't have to make
moonshine you could probably just make
you could it just see what they have
yeah I mean it moonshine would be easy
to make cuz I think you can just make it
out of
sugar I don't even think you need
anything other than the sugar James
Holmes said my great great grandpa was a
Moonshiner yeah yeah I think a lot of
people were Zach says uh by the way I
showed Tom this earlier but a show I
grew up on Grim Adventures of Billy and
Mandy I remember that show uh has a song
in it by your guy's friend B yeah that's
um he actually did a lot of songs for
cartoons and stuff back then a lot of
songs are really funny I actually really
like them he's a good Lyricist he seems
like a nice man I don't know you knew
somebody that dated him right or was
married to him or something yeah my ex
[__] buddy in-law [__] your buddy
in-law I'm call her buddy Tanya Tanya
lived with them I think they may have
been married but they were living them
for a long
time yeah yeah Tanya was a super cute
Chanel girl she sold so much [__]
Chanel [__] back was up in Boston she
worked at uh bloy
Dales she was a good salesperson she
look like a model but she ended up with
voler that was she had a whole stack of
[__] love
letters from
uh was that goth kid from [__]
propaganda magazine that was just
[__] oh that guy um da the super hot
one super what was his name uh [__] John
John kovak kovak yeah that's it yeah
John kovc was in love with her yeah and
it was him [__] his name he had
photographs and
[__] yeah I always thought that dude was
super hot cuz I used to buy a propaganda
whenever I could find it yeah you know
it's this this is sad but it's like they
didn't really sell it in a lot of places
it's you know in [__] Florida yeah so
it's like I had to come to when I lived
in Daytona I had to come to Orlando and
go to the Virgin mega store at Downtown
Disney which is now in Disney Springs
which you know the Virgin mega store
isn't there anymore Disney Springs is
still there yeah but I had to go in
there and every now and then they would
have it well I think it only came out
four times a year right it was it was
quarterly yeah because it was a big it
was a big fat yeah magazine so it wasn't
like you know
yeah evidently that magazine didn't make
any money it was uh I can imagine it
probably did not we we grew up with it
it was quite a cultural [__] thing
for the goth SE it's legendary like in
the goth scene and it
was basically like a gay dude he was one
that put it together and he was a
photographer and
um he would set up all these photo
shoots with uh good-looking goth kids
from the time I call them kids they were
over 21 most of them I believe yeah and
they would just do these [__] really
cool photo shoots scenarios they end up
in those machine end up in those
magazines and
uh they weren't nude a little they maybe
like semi- nude like girls stucking with
the ass hanging out in the g string or
something and maybe some topl but a lot
of them were kind of like fashion Orient
fashion and fetish Orient fetish and
[__] um artistic looking they weren't
porn really yeah they were classy yeah
and they were they were black and white
most of them yeah and
uh one of the male models
uh was John John kovak and he became
like the main goth heart throb all the
girls [__] love this dude and he's a
good look he was a good-looking dude oh
yeah when he got a little bit older he
did he he he he didn't look like that
anymore he he was still a good-looking
guy um but when he got famous he was
extremely skinny extremely skinny and uh
I'll show you a picture
of and he just couldn't maintain that
particular look he had a band too yeah
that's right you
know yeah I remember that's like I used
to think about that when back when I
bought it all the time like back in the
90s and I was just like this magazine
cannot be making any money because it's
like one it's the distribution you
couldn't find it hardly anywhere except
in like real cities and it probably was
very expensive to
produce and it wasn't I mean it was
slightly expensive but it wasn't all
that expensive for you know how many
pages it was so and I'm like and I can't
imagine more than a few thousand people
are like buying this you know what I
mean oh yeah I remember that picture
that was John I remember that picture
yeah I remember one they did kind of a
um uh with him in like the the uniforms
of C of certain yeah yeah they did a lot
of like [__] uh Germanic
provocative dramatic looks kind of like
Death in
June kind of aesthetic you know what I
mean which is in like I said flirts a
little with provocation let's put it
that way very old school old school goth
John
kak I like that picture too yeah let me
see if I can find the
old Ben said have I seen American Horror
Story New York season 11 extremely gay
uh I have not but now that you said that
uh that immediately pequs my interest
cuz I like watching anything that's like
extremely
gay you know how much I love that
stuff I haven't you know I started
watching the first season of American
Horror Story and I was just kind of like
man this seems like something I could
really get into and then I just kind of
like spaced out and like forgot about it
and so now how many seasons of it are we
in and I'm just like well [__] now it's
going to take like [__] forever to
catch up see that's that's him later oh
okay well he's still looking good though
that was that was maybe that was maybe
10 years later okay that's that still
works yeah he just didn't look exactly
like he did that still work well nobody
does nobody does from when they were
that young yeah you can't like look the
same forever it's when he looked like
it's when he looked like this that's
when [__] all the girls were [__]
running after him yeah yeah well I mean
look at that face that's like the
perfect like male model face trying to
find he's got like the big lips and
everything trying to find his little his
little German Soldier
[__] bones and whatnot
the little German Soldier photograph
look like it might have been [__]
thrown down the memory hole wait a
minute here it is no I was going to say
they were pretty famous I I have that
issue somewhere yeah yeah yeah I I have
that issue yeah looking like Martin Gore
look at that he does look just like
Martin Gore in that picture actually
yeah they did a lot of stuff that's not
Martin Gore no it's him I'm just kidding
I'm just saying that in the people or
people video Martin gor from dep PES
mode wor that exact pretty much that
exact outfit ex that was that was a
[__] early 9s goth look bigger than
[__] late ' 80s too that was going on oh
yeah Death in June all the all the
German
neofolk kind of yeah that that was a big
that was a big Sub sub genre yeah which
like I said I think a lot of people
don't realize that it's like the whole
you know when you just say goth you mean
like one thing but it's like it's not
it's like a million things there's
there's like 40 bajillion like little
sub
genres of like different [__] that was
going on and like you know we kind of
knew what was going on with this and
that and the other thing but it's like
most people had like preferences I think
that's him too it might be yeah see that
that's the kind of [__] I'm talking
about this is the [__] that went pretty
[__] far I'm pretty sure that's him
right yeah see so like I said and they
did that for provocation purposes they
wanted you to get pissed yeah they
wanted you to get kind of like or either
that or like oh oh yeah yeah they were
fetishizing it right yeah that's what it
was
yeah
oh remember this
what I have that yeah I remember that I
have that issue on cover it's in it's
right here you got one of these probably
worth a lot of money either I still have
it or I can't remember because I did
sell some of my magazines to um DJ uh
azy in uh I remember this one but I did
have I do have that I think this is when
John was getting spicy with the with
with with the German nationalism yeah I
remember that I remember that photo too
cuz I also had that that issue yeah that
[__] weighs about 100
lb see I like that though it's a look I
like it's the Hain Chic was going on I
like that look I mean I lik a lot of
different looks but I do like that look
heroin Chic was going on at the to you
know oracle says my latest spooky movie
was rewatching happy death day to you I
actually really enjoyed the happy death
Day movies I didn't really expect to I
don't know why I'm not I'm not usually
hugely into horror comedy but but I
thought that was like such a cool
premise and like the girl that was in it
the you know the woman that's in it is
like is so good and like so appealing
that it's just like really I just really
enjoyed them I think we saw happy death
day to you in the theater and then we
saw the first one like later on we
actually watched last night because if
you remember I don't was this Wednesday
that you said that you wanted to watch
all the Christopher Lee Dracula movies
like the ones so we had done um Dracula
like the first one Horror of Dracula
which is what it's called in the US I
think it's just called Dracula in the UK
which came out in 1958 and then the
second one is Dracula Prince of Darkness
but I couldn't find that [__] anywhere
streaming so we went to what I think is
the third one or maybe the fourth one
which was Dracula's risen from the grave
which was on HBO Max which I have so we
watched that one last night didn't love
it I think that Christopher Lee should
have been in it
more um so but I don't know it was
pretty good but we might review it on
Monday or we might watch something else
and I'm not really sure cuz they have a
bunch of other ones available on Max and
on um Amazon Prime so we'll see we've
done Dracula ad80
1972 because the thing about up until
Dracula 809 1972 all of the Dracula
movies were obviously like set at the
you know at the end of the 19th century
like the book was so I think Tom would
like likes it better when it's said in
the modern era you know so maybe some of
SE like scars of Dracula or something
but yeah Dracula has risen from the
grave was it's pretty good but I think
it needed more Christopher Le yeah they
made they made some
mistakes I mean if you're going to have
Dracula you better give Dracula some
[__] lines to say he better have some
scenes in it he better Dracula the [__]
out really you
really and you got Christopher Lee you
went through all that trouble to get his
ass and you don't give him very much to
say
as as kind of good British production
was it's [__] a trip that they didn't
have a better script written with
dialogue for him and more to
do but they weren't expanding on vampire
lore I find that strange almost kind of
like they were afraid to go
there yeah I don't really know like I
said I kind of want to watch all of them
in sequence because I've seen them all
but I don't think I ever sat down and
watched them in order you know what I
mean like I kind of like kind of watched
them all over like different times
Dracula comes back just to get revenge
and he does get his
revenge but it should have been more of
that you know what I mean what's what's
what's dra going to do once he has his
revenge is he going to rebuild his
castle is he gonna move go back to sleep
for a little while yeah is he going to
go somewhere else is he going to have a
new woman is he going to have a new a
new uh
Herm of vampire broads you know what I
mean that's another thing not enough
boobies yeah I mean there was a lot of
cleavage in this one yeah and but not
enough boobies and the way they wrote
the
story Dracula was after the the blonde
hottie um but there was a girl that was
into him and and and she's like what do
you want her for you got me well he was
after her because she one because of the
Purity issue like I was telling you
before and two because she was the niece
of the dude that had [__] him yeah but
it didn't matter right I'm just saying
it shouldn't have mattered from
Dracula's point of view he should have
just says I'm I have all y'all all I'm
an equal opportunity yeah he goes he
goes I like the good girls and the bad
girls I just eat all of y'all yep all
y'all are going to come with me and
you're going to do what I say but they
didn't give him enough
lines you know what I mean they're
trying to make Dracula too much like a
monster instead of a a man that's yeah
that's been you know infected with
vampirism that's what he really should
although I did like the I did like the
scenes where he came into that chick's
room because she was all about it CU you
know he has that hypnosis thing and it's
Christopher Lee I was like yeah
Christopher Lee showed up at my window
I'd probably be like yeah right you know
what I mean but my gripe is that the
girl the woman that was into him when
she expressed her [__] love for him
after she was partially turned he killed
her yeah you know he's like I don't need
that [__] [__] yeah which uh you
would think that a [__] ancient
vampire who' been around for hundreds of
years would have known how to use people
be like okay yeah you're going to be you
know I like you too you're going to hang
out we're going to get we're going to
get some we're going to get some more
Brides together yeah that kind of right
I know that like if Tom was a vampire oh
yeah may herum I mean he would have a
whole her' be a whole her but Dracula
had a herum of them I I know you he had
three of them Dracula had three of them
was trying to get a fourth or fifth one
yeah maybe I'd be your favorite one but
you would you'd be the you'd be the
chief one you'd be you be like You' be
you'd be the head
wife I'd put all the other ones under
under under your control you'd be in
charge well at least I know that if we
ever get turned into vampire yeah Tom's
getting a herum I don't get a herum but
he gets one you can have one you can
have a Herm of women I can't have a
herum of men uh if I approve of them oh
I don't know if I like if I appr if I
approve if I approve of depends on what
the deal is depends depends on what the
deal double standard Tom double standard
depend it depends you know as long as
you're not a threat then yeah oh I see
depends on depends on if I like them but
don't I
mean okay you wouldn't think like women
would be a threat to me I'd make sure
that wouldn't happen oh okay there's
nothing they could do nothing they could
do to
you this just look really funny it would
be your sisters I kind of figured I kind
of fig it would be your Sister Wives cuz
I like most dudes are kind of like that
they're like well yeah I want a Haram
women and their wife's like yeah I'd
like a heram a men too they're like oh
no no no
no no only I get to have Herm you know I
can work something
out like I said I well see that's the I
would not want a Herm of men because
Jesus Christ that's what I was thinking
one man is enough of a p like yeah but
if you had a harm of women I would get a
harm of men just despite you like just
because I could you know what I mean
that's why yeah see that that's spiteful
thinking so well no I'm just saying
should be you know well because it's
well you might might you might want a
couple real young ones or something you
get to have one so you you might want a
couple real young ones that you what I
don't get anything you know what you get
to have whatever you want I don't get to
have nothing nobody said that nobody
said that well yeah that's what I'm
saying nobody said that I'm just saying
that it's just like you know nobody said
that in reality I wouldn't want a Herm
of dudes because that would be a pain in
the that's what I was thinking I was
think she she Jen Jenny's more likely to
want a her a girls really yeah so but
see I would like I said I because dude
dudes just be more trouble but the only
the only thing I could see that that you
might go for is like a much younger guy
who's kind of like a kind of like a
servant
almost well like as long as they weren't
pain or like a douchebag or something
yeah you know you know I you can see you
know the guys in his 20s or something
dude is real sippy I don't know yeah
that [__] served you I can I can see
you probably go for that Ben says a
heram of non-binary asexual furin yeah
okay yeah o oh can I have a harm of uh f
yeah you can have all the Fooda you want
okay all right then I'm on
board yeah you guys don't know what a
Fooda is I didn't even think a Fooda is
a [__] an anime a Japanese
anime they're not transsexual they're
what do you call them
hermaphrodites yeah they're
hermaphrodites they're girls with it
mean it roughly translates to dick girl
yeah dick girl it's a girl basically
yeah it's a one
she's got a vagina and everything but
she also has P yeah and it's and it's
[__] unreasonably large enough to
scare you we know what food are I fig
some people don't know what a food said
just in just in case anybody didn't know
so I I will have a her of Fooda then I
have a whole bunch of Fooda I like that
idea you try to get the food or Peg me
and [__] exactly so I know what she's
thinking it's winwin I know what she's
thinking balls or no balls and big old
[__] 13 14 inch long Fooda yeah see
um I'm ambivalent they can have
[__] thinks man it's all right I'm not
averse to balls or no everything is
mental mental wrestling match with
Jen she's trying to get back around to
that [__] whole [__] anual
fixation she has maybe I should learn
like some animation and then I could
like and I could do a deep fake and I
could do a deep
fake I'll try to make it look like
realistic and stuff I don't have enough
money to pay somebody else to do it so
I'd have to learn to do it Joseph said
Christopher Lee's favorite Hammer movie
The Devil rides out that's actually a
great one um yeah that's based on uh
what's his name um Dennis Wheatley
that's his name right um You would
probably really like that movie The
Devil rides out we should yeah we should
probably um do that one of these days
yeah I mean so I mean so far I kind of
liked the
British vampire movies you know with
Christopher Lee they're okay they're
pretty
good the quality is pretty good for the
time yeah um but it's not expanding out
on the on vampire lore or lore
or building on the character of of
Dracula so far yeah he's still a generic
monster right right right I mean and
then William Marshall
actually the the the the thing from what
do you call it [__] blackula and
scream blackula scream that those two
movies actually expanded on vampire
lore that they took it to to the
interview with vampire levels because
those movies actually they actually uh
inspired and rice more than the than
some of the old vampire
movies yeah and I mean I really like the
blackula movies black screen black
screen yeah they're kind of like they're
pretty good vampire movies yeah they're
really they're kind they're kind of
doing Innovative stuff with the because
they're asking the question what is it
like to live as a vampire what would
your world be like yeah and so far
that's not being addressed in
these yeah I mean this one they're just
kind of like I said still keeping to
like the classic as far as I remember
this was only like the third or fourth
one so they're basically just trying to
retell the classic story over again
because all that happens in this one is
that you know at the end of Dracula
Prince of Darkness like Dracula got
frozen or something like that so they
thought that he'd been destroyed but
like all the people in the village are
like well but still like we still feel
the evil or whatever and then this
priest goes up there and like tries to
exercise the evil from the castle but
then during the hike they kind of
accidentally wake him back up again like
that's what usually happens and then
he's like oh I'm going to I'm going to
go [__] up the towns folk and he he
mostly wants to get revenge on the one
priest that put the big cross in his
castle door and the exorcism over his
castle CU he was M you know what I mean
one of the best looking scenes that have
anything to do with vampires out of
these old movies came out of scream back
of the scream when he turned that voodoo
priest into a vampire down in New
Orleans and he's impressed he's like man
look at these clothes look at me I'm a
vampire man I look [__] and he tried
to look at himself in the mirror and he
couldn't see
himself yeah and [__] M waly you know
played by William Marshall
also knows black he goes uh yeah you
can't see yourself in those days are
over and he's like well let's let's go
out to the club man we're going to have
fun and he goes oh no no no no and he
goes what do you mean we're vampires now
we can't go out and he's like and then
he goes no you can't socialize with
moral and why not you know they go CU
you'll lead them back here where we
sleep and they'll kill us you know and
he's like so what am I supposed to do he
say you will stay right here and obey me
and he go what I'm your slave now and he
goes
yes yeah sucks to be you yeah you're my
slave I made you you know in this whole
that was the first time that was ever
addressed that I can think of in these
old vampire movies that if you were a
master vampire and you made other
vampires they were your
slaves they you did what they said or
they killed you cuz you they were a lot
stronger than you and they made you for
a reason to be a servant to
them well they wanted your house that
was the whole premise of r
that he that was the whole premise of
all that damn Interview with the Vampire
stuff you made it D to vampire so you
could steal his house but you didn't
make him a [__] strong vampire you
made him your
servant because if you could do that I
mean most people probably would yeah you
didn't worry about money you just turn
rich people into vampires and make them
your service see that's what appeals to
me mhm cuz you're going to need a lot of
money if you're going to live forever MH
so
you better like go find some
[__] that's got like a [__] T
that's like a billionaire yeah and then
turn him into like a wimpy ass vampire
but they show that the money eventually
runs out because whatever your form of
business was you can't maintain it
forever because you're a vampire you
can't you can't move around during the
day and you're only going to be able to
fool people for so long remember
eventually the plantation rose up
against them and drove them out yeah
and you had to have a bunch of lawyers
crooked lawyers that would [__] you
know handle all your money business you
really have to like there was a big
there was a big it was being a vampire
was a job if you wanted possessions you
you had to take care of legal ownership
it's hard to do when you don't have a
[__] identity your identity is
hundreds of years old you have to use
you you're you're making other people
vampires so you can urp their identity
as living people and that's only good
for so long yeah like man this dude's
102 he [__] looks like he's
so you got to keep changing them out
it's making me tired just thinking about
it thank you Jeffy art just watched
YouTuber James summ Merton's video essay
on vampires in queer culture it's worth
watching just for the fun can't be
costumes alone uh that actually sounds
really good so I'm going to have to like
check that out uh so thank you for the
recommendation and thank you for the
Super Chat Joseph says have you ever
done a show about the Hermetic Order of
the Golden Dawn yes we did one on uh
yeah well we did one on um on on on
alist Crowley we did do a show on aliser
Crowley like a long time
ago but I don't know if we did one about
that specifically but we did talk about
that like on the show a lot yeah Ben
said just get an old castle in the
middle of nowhere that everyone is
afraid to visit that's kind of what you
have to do yeah and well I mean the
thing about there was more to that story
too right well go ahead what you say
well that's the thing it's like even if
you did that you know there's going to
be villagers you got to like go out in
the public sometimes so everybody's
going to I think that [__] is a
vampire eventually somebody's going to
try to prop buy that property yeah or
eventually somebody's going to like twig
on to like what you're up to and you
know that could like go badly Dracula
solution was down there in Romania or in
Transylvania he had a whole Army of
gypsies Gypsy gagsters basically that
protected him and did a lot of his
bidding and they were kind
of uh what's they were kind of uh
holding the the local Village in Terror
that as long as they gave up offerings
every now and then he wouldn't come go
down there and [__] him up and they also
had to protect him and they had to
protect him in exchange of all that so
the the locals knew who he
was they're scared of him yeah which you
could go that route too but that was in
the olden days before telecommunications
you know it would be much harder now
much harder today you couldn't take over
a whole
town you could back then but you you
couldn't take over
town in a modern era yeah Ben said or
set up a Family Trust and Lease
everything from yourself that might be
the route to go like where you can just
like say that you're a descendant like
this is just like always your son or
whatever like maybe you could do that
but it would still like take a lot of
legal wrangling I think yeah and maybe
you'd have to make your lawyer into a
vampire team so he could like You' have
to make him into a thrw so he'd like do
all your bidding all the time and do all
your [__] legal [__] I think that's
what he's trying to do to Renfield I
guess the process isn't perfect
that they can [__] them up sometimes and
you can't use them cu the thing about
what was Renfield 4 the thing about a th
is that ostensibly you're making them
sort of a quasi vampire because you want
somebody that can still walk around in
the daytime and is still mostly human
but you still want somebody that kind of
has powers and also that will just do
whatever you say so I'm not entirely
sure like how all of that works oh well
according to the movies they were being
promised vampirism
well yeah after service yeah yeah yeah
so they could live
forever uh but that wasn't actually what
they were going to do they they in the
stories they always betrayed him and
killed him when they were done with him
yeah in Fright Night uh Jerry Dandridge
who was the vampire in that he had I
guess you'd call it a thraw his name was
Billy Cole and he was a person in the
sense that he could walk around in the
daytime but he was also kind of like a
vampire because he wasn't um like you
could shoot him and he'd still like get
back up again but when they staked him
like he melted and died and stuff so he
was still like partly a vampire but not
enough that he couldn't like walk around
in the daytime you know well according
to according to an
rice it all mattered on how much blood
he gave you yeah they when they show
when they show it in the old movies he's
biting the girls and they somehow become
a
vampire and right said yeah he's biting
them but he's also giving them some of
his blood yeah and the more blood that
more of his blood they drink the more of
his power they will get which kind which
makes sense actually right and then to
make a a
thw which is a slave basically and it's
like a part vampire slave somebody who's
just and their minds are kind of [__]
up evidently you're only giving them a
few
drops just enough to take control over
them
right yeah guess
some of the in some of those vampire the
stop books though you
know when L would make a vampire a
strong one he'd give him a lot yeah you
know which would make him a little
stronger at Birth at vampire
birth I kind of like I thought and it's
been a while since I've read the
original Bram Stoker novel but I thought
in the Dracula book like if you just got
bit by a vampire and and they didn't
kill you like if it didn't bite you if
if he didn't bite you again you would
recover and it would be fine but what
they did and I'm pretty sure what
Dracula did to Lucy in the novel was
that he came back on I believe it was
three nights and drained more blood and
drained more blood and drain more blood
and then after she died she turned into
a vampire yeah so I'm guessing that
because he bit Mina too but she didn't
turn into a vampire either but she still
had the power like she could like look
into his mind and [__] because it was
like some kind of like psychic link that
was established between them thank you
murder Hornet thank you very much thanks
well that's the same thing with
um in the an rice books though they had
that there bunch of psychic links could
happen but it was
dep and Rice's explanation was it
depended on how much blood they gave you
right yeah they were drinking your blood
but they were also making you drink some
of their
blood and you once you started sucking
on it you'd [__] want more more and
more of it and they'd have to stop you
yeah but it killed you when you drank a
bunch of it yeah but maybe in the you
know I know that these writers are
making the lore up as they go yeah but
you could interpret it the an rice way
it was like yeah he was coming drinking
her but on that last night he gave her
some blood before she died and then she
died right from drinking the blood then
she came back well see that's what Ben's
saying is like didn't he share his blood
with her or is that from later material
see that's kind of what I don't remember
because I thought and I could be totally
wrong cuz like I said it's been a while
since I've read the Dracula the original
novel I thought that he just drank
Lucy's blood over successive nights so
she got sicker and sicker and sicker um
she probably would have died sooner
except they kept giving her blood
transfusions you know what I mean like
all her suitors did so but after she
died she came back as a vampire I don't
think and I could be totally wrong but I
don't think in the novel he gave her any
of his blood yeah but I could be wrong
about that I could be misremembering it
so they're saying that it spread like
the way it is with the werewolf just
getting bitten it's it's like like if
you die from it then you'll come back as
a vampire right which like I said
because I remember when I read that
novel as a kid thinking well [__] if
this was the way it worked if everybody
that got that died from eventually died
from a vampire by like turned into a
vampire too like eventually the whole
population of the Earth would be
vampires right and I think somebody has
even figured out mathematically how long
that would take to happen because of
course they have but um but so it makes
a lot more sense and I'm pretty sure
that that was a later extrapolation that
you know the vampire had to give you
yeah like if they just drained your
blood you would just die yeah um but
they have to give you some of the blood
to to like you know deliberately make
you into a vampire other than it was
just kind of like a you know oh I bit
this person and they died and then they
just woke up again you know what I mean
well that's the way an that's more like
a zombie thing and rice would explain it
that way I don't know if she invented
that system or just got it from other
movies but it makes a lot more sense
they're drinking from you to kill you
right not to make you a vampire yeah
they just want your blood you're just
food you're just food right he can make
you a vampire but the only way to do is
he has to give you some of his blood
right and that makes a lot more sense
and they because they don't want
everybody that they feed from to become
a vampire cuz like I said they'd be too
much of a problem these are just food
they're disposable yeah
and like I said you know it would just
be the whole world would be it would be
like a zombie apocalypse an Rice's
system is a lot better because she's
like you know well the vampires are real
careful about who they would make
another vampire you had to have a
certain look and you had to have a
certain uh amount of money that helped
too or you or they just had to like you
but there was a certain look they were
looking for somebody who was goodlook
who could pull it off and
um
the more they liked you the more blood
they'd give you but if they gave you too
much they wouldn't you know you could
theoretically drink all that vampire's
blood who's given it to you and kill
that vampire and have all of his power
but they didn't want that they just give
you some they wanted you strong enough
to survive but not so strong to be a
threat that's that's what they were
doing that kind of checks out even with
a lot of the older movies I mean that
does make a lot more sense yeah Jeffy
Ard said instead of a thw I could see
modern vampires creating a service using
an app daylight services delivery
coughin security Etc vampire
entrepreneurism yeah that's exactly what
would happen I feel like if you guys
have never seen the 1983 movie The
Hunger which was based on the Whitley
streber novel um that's actually one of
my favorite vampire movies of whole of
of all time and it kind of because it
kind of it's slightly Supernatural but
it does kind of go into the more
scientific genetic kind of um angle on
it because Miriam the the Vampire who's
like been alive for thousands of years
they imply that she like was turned in
like ancient Egypt or something she
keeps trying to find Companion vampires
that will stay with her like forever so
she finds a human that she likes she
exchanges blood with them and then they
live for like two 300 years but then
they start to like really rapidly age
because there's some kind of like um the
you know the the there's some kind of
compatibility issue with vampire blood
and human blood and it's a really good
story like I thought it was like a
really good angle and the shitty thing
too is that everybody that she turns
like that after two 300 years they start
aging like super rapidly but they're
still alive like they still can't die
they're still Immortal but their bodies
start disintegrating which to me I
always thought that was like the most
[__] horrible idea and I'm like what
a great idea for like for a vampire
thing because it's like the whole appeal
of the vamp Empire Mythos is that you
are young and hot forever and like your
body is you know stays the way it was
when you were young or whatever but it's
like the fact that you're still stuck in
this body and it's just like aging and
falling apart and all this other kind of
[__] is like really horrifying so I
thought that was like a great idea
another angle though that an rice came
up with was was a about a dude named
Magnus Magnus was the guy who made lad
into a vampire and he was a
sorcerer remember that one mhm he was a
sorcerer he stole vampirism he wasn't
made a vampire he stole it and he was an
old Alchemist and
sorcerer who F found out the vampires
were
real and tracked down where one of them
was
buried and he dug up an old mummified
looking vampire that had been like
starved of blood for a long long time
and he made an incision in it and drank
from it that killed him but turned him
into a vampire when he came up he was an
old man vampire didn't have any teeth
just he had fangs but no teeth and he
was just [__]
hideous he lived for a long time like
that and uh he figured out that he had
kind of broken the rules of a vampire he
couldn't he couldn't do much because the
way he
looked so he was trying to pick a
sucessor and he piic picked a bunch of
them but they failed the only one that
passed was theat
that's mean and he said to be a vampire
long term you'd have to be good-look you
had to be young yeah because you're
going to stay like that forever yeah cuz
like what would be the point of like
having like osteoporosis and [__] like
that Magnus was strong though he was
super it was just that he couldn't he
couldn't do anything socially you know
what I mean he couldn't he he he lived
as like basically a Hermit he couldn't
be around anybody well it's the same he
just so hideous looking it was the same
kind of rule it's like that's why they
said well you didn't make you won't make
a child into a vampire because obviously
going to be a child forever and child
forever that would be a horrifying fate
to be trapped in and that they wouldn't
survive over time right they couldn't
survive on their own type of deal well
yeah and that's how that happened Joseph
says um in saber Higgins the Dracula
tape Dracula claims that the only reason
Lucy was bad was that they kept giving
her blood transfusions without checking
the blood types yeah that was another
thing and I thought that they at least
knew kind of something about blood
typing in the late 19th century when
that book was written but maybe not
because the fact that her suitors just
came in they're like hey we got blood
here give her some you know what I mean
but it's like well you can't just do
that willy-nilly maybe they didn't know
that back then I think they did that
kind of [__] back then yeah blood's
blood yeah it's all blood who
cares I think it coagulates if it's the
wrong time not so much I'm actually not
really sure what happens but it's not
good it's not good um Tammy says anybody
remember the cop show forever night from
1992 where the main character was a cop
and a vampire I vaguely remember that I
don't think I ever saw it but I remember
seeing ads remember seeing that yeah
remember seeing ads for it
yeah Sebastian says vampires are real I
think they drink blood well yeah I mean
there are people that drink blood for
sure does it make them live forever uh
no probably not although how would we
know if they were really good at like
hiding it you know maybe I'd say no
probably not no cuz the lore has the
lore that we were hearing about vampires
is new it's not old so no if the
vampires really existed that lore would
be very
old yeah we did a show not too long ago
about vampires and werewolves it's not
old enough and stuff like that well and
a lot of the old [__] about vampires and
werewolves is like kind of weird like
and and it's been like replaced with
other things like the original
particularly from the movies The
Originals you wouldn't
recognize I think the original is more
like a
stroy that's probably the original and
then some of the
other old vampire stories that kind of
more closely resembles
a a zombie yeah they were more like
ghouls like a zombie or a ghoul like
they weren't like all hot and swave and
everything like that they were just like
gross yeah zombie type dudes that
crawled out of graves with their shrouds
on and they were all bloody and stuff
yeah and they were kind of
mindless yeah there's like anistic Yeah
The U the whole Suave vampire thing
that's Bell the GOI he invented that I
mean pretty much yeah because even in
the novel he wasn't I guess he was kind
of super swab later but it's like he
wasn't really swaave he was more like a
rat likee old man he's what he's exactly
what Max Shrek was showing in narat yeah
that's a lot closer to what he was like
in the book he did look younger I think
like once he moved to England and
started like drinking people like he did
appear younger they do mention that in
the novel but yeah when you first meet
him he looks like a creature like
doesn't look like a person so he's not
all smooth like [__] B GOI so yeah I
think that's where that whole like
Smooth Aristocrat thing came from from
Bell go but and he had done it on stage
before he was in the movie so I think
that's probably where that came from
yeah Jeffy art said I loved forever
night it's evid free on YouTube I think
they're yeah you used to stay up
watching it on CBS after Late Night with
Letterman it was the kind it was the
show that made me go from being afraid
of vampires to having major crushes on
them
that's pretty cool yeah they were
talking about like vampires V say
Richard Ramirez tried that out yeah it's
just I don't think drinking drinking
blood isn't going to do anything for you
no HRT will but not drinking
blood inject testosterone that that'll
that that that that'll do something but
it's like drinking blood well if you
drink the blood it doesn't just just
digest it it just digest it just like
anything else that youat or drink yeah
yeah that's yeah you might as well just
eat a steak Yeah it tastes a lot better
I'm sure than like [__] human blood
mhm so I you know I I don't know but uh
all right so it's almost 9:00 and you
seem like you're kind of getting ready
to yeah let's go ahead and shut it down
we're going to get ready to go yeah we
got to get ready to oh wait so Danny
rolling has a question first okay what's
Tom's opinion on the Harley-Davidson uh
pan americ motorcycle and would it be
good for off-road riding I don't know
that one is that is that that new liquid
cooled head engine that that's in that
one I think I think and I heard that
they were do doing kind of like an
adventure Tour Bike must be that must be
what he's talking
about but I will tell you this just off
the top of my
head and I'm not a Harley fanatic I came
from Japanese sport bikes then went on
to
bus a lot of my friends have Harley and
I hang out with [__] guys in
motorcycle gangs you know [__]
warlocks and
stuff Harley-Davidson motorcycles are
very good quality motorcycles for what
their intended purpose was which is like
long distance endurance riding touring
you know good they're they're western
style they kind of they're kind of
modeled after the old cowboy western
horse you carry saddle
bags some of them have hard bags big
[__] fairing on the front of it and
great sound
systems and uh Harley really got them
straightened out they're they're good um
they're as good as a Japanese
Cruiser but I think in a way better
because they're kind of the
original um build quality is nice now
they have idiosyncrasies you know things
have certain bearings have to be
replaced and you have to stay on top of
certain things but that's it's not hard
it's very easy to work on those bikes uh
there's the tutorials are everywhere and
if you're in the United States the
supply Parts is just [__] very easy
to get hold get a hold of and the motors
themselves are very kind of agricultural
real
simple they produce a lot of torque
they're undertuned or detuned which
means that they could produce a lot more
power but they've they've D- tuned them
to run a lot Mell more mellow so you can
get more engine life out of
one they make a lot of
torque and uh which is you know the
[__] acceleration and pulling power
the ability to [__] move from a dead
stop up up to speed you know they got a
lot of torque kind of like a tractor and
they people get confused they got big
displacement Motors but they get very
good gas mileage uh uh you know [__]
you can get they got Harley's out Harley
engines out there they get 45 miles per
gallon um most of them are probably more
like 40 35 especially if they're
weighted down with a bunch of
electronics and body parts and [__] you
know and [__]
accessories but um pretty much anything
from them I don't it they're good
they're good
products and they were dealing with that
live wire it was in a it was a an
electric motorcycle I liked how it
looked but electric motorcycles just
they're not ready if you ask me and that
they wanted a lot of money for that
thing and uh I liked how it looked
though but just not really that
practical takes a long time to recharge
them yeah I haven't seen it so I don't
really know look good look real cool
yeah futuristic like a futuristic
[__] Harley hot rod kind of like a
Sportster and a like a kind of like a
Harley Sportster and a and a [__]
bule S1 had a
baby all right retr futuristic looking
oh yeah I like that I like that
aesthetic very retro
futuristic all right so I guess we're
going to wrap it up cuz we got
to hit the road in a little bit uh so
yeah thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for you guys' super chats
hopefully you have a good weekend coming
up we'll be back on Monday evening
talking about a movie I don't know it it
might be Dracula's risen from the grave
it might be something else because we
might watch something else over the
weekend that we talk about so you know
hopefully you guys can join us for that
so thanks everybody for dropping by once
again have a good weekend and we'll see
you guys on Monday good